BOOKEND CONNOR  FROM
CHIASSON.
GOT PAST
PLAYING.
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT PUCK EVER
WENT  NETHERS.
HE'S BEEN SNAKE BITTEN A LITTLE
BOARDS.
FINDS IT WAY TO ROB
GOOD ON THEM.
>> Josh: HE WILL TAKE IT AGAINST
HORVAT WHO WINS IT CLEANLY. POW
>> RESTART FACE-OFF.
HUGHES WALKING THE LINE, SHOT  .
THAT WAS HIS ONLY PROBLEM.
>> THAT'S HIS ONLY PEARSON JUST
THROUGH HIM.
COULD NOT SHOVE IT IN.
STARS GET A CHANGE IN,
STARS ALKS IT PAST FAKSA.
CURLS BACK TO UY NOW HAS A STIC.
AND LUKE MILLER.
5:08 LEFT HERE IN THE SECOND
PERIOD.
MILLER WINS IT CLEANLY OETTINGE.
IMMEDIATELY TO PLAYING WIDE ON .
AND HE CREATES A BIT OF A
SCREEN, PETTERSSONTHE SECOND
PERIOD.
JUST UNDER 6:00 IN.
CANUCKS GOT
WAY TO THE BOX TO NO AVAIL.
>> HE'S HAVING INTO THE STARS
ZONE.
OETTINGER KEEP IT IN.
ABLE TO TO THEAGE.
DEMKO STILL CHIPPED INTO THEEST
LOB, KLINGBERG AGAIN WILL TAKE
IT BETWEEN THE DEFENSIVE
BULL'S EYE.
BO
JAMMED ALONG THE WALL.T
LOOSE, AND GET